former news anchor kathy lee gifford has
shifted her passion to becoming a
songwriter playwright and author so
jillian caught up with her just in time
for the release of her new book and new
movie take a look
cathy you're a busy woman you have a lot
going on i love following along with
everything that you're doing but let's
jump right into it you were telling me a
fun fact before we even started this
interview so what came first your book
or your movie
well chicken with the egg right
uh you know most people assume that that
movies are made from a book that's not
true at all this is the opposite i was
uh i had written a film three and a half
years ago with my friend nicole c mullen
that had an
outrageous reaction on youtube and it
proved to me that this is what i was
supposed to do is write that that movie
was called the god who sees
and millions of people watched it had it
it was just anointed of the holy spirit
people were being healed people were
being saved people were not committing
suicide because they did they finally
believed that god saw them i mean i
could tell
this is not something that two women
write that's just you know another piece
of theater another song whatever it had
a life to it and it was vibrant it was
powerful
she's traveling
what we wrote is technically called an
oratorio it's storytelling but with
music underneath it and i have the
national symphony orchestra players
underneath me 65 of them with some of
the most outrageous music you've heard
in in years i think well and kathy i
feel like you've just entered this next
chapter and kind of have found your
calling out such a successful journalism
career and now here you are spreading
your your message of positivity and also
we talked about when you are a grandma
you have this beautiful family i know
your daughter-in-law erica from out here
in las vegas do you just feel like you
are where you're meant to be right now
can you tell
yeah everybody goes how could you leave
your dream job with regis leave your
dream job with soda no
i'm doing my dream job right now this is
what i
didn't even realize god was it was what
was doing inside me but i came out of
the womb wanting to be an actress and a
singer and a and a writer
and i've done that all along people just
didn't know i was doing it all along
after you go on my
imdb
it's a
pages and pages long and it was it's of
tv shows and movies and broadway and and
i looked at it i sort of said you got to
see that i go why i said you're not
going to believe how much stuff you've
done i know really i could just do it
the bible comes to life with music and
narration in ways you've never
experienced